because
so what's a typical day look like for
you a typical day it's all very random i
wake up probably around 11 or 12 take a
dump
take a dump wake up uh check my twitter
facebook emails answer emails
grab some lunch or make something more
of the same i mean all throughout the
day sounds like a good day anything that
starts off with the dump is yeah to me
so i'm curious about one thing so i had
dinner with you once i had the pleasure
of having dinner with you once at a
random mexican restaurant in the very
middle of the night
and we were interrupted so many times by
your fans by people who recognize you so
how often does this happen and honestly
does it ever get really annoying it can
be annoying when i'm eating especially
like what you witnessed
because you know i just want to spend
time with friends and just hang out and
be able to talk without you know someone
coming up and kind of just like or
sometimes in the middle of eating i'm
like taking a bite of something i'm like
and they're like hey david i was like
i'm like you know
let me just finish this but at the same
time i'd rather have them come up than
to sit at a table over here and
stare at me so okay so here's another
thing i'm really curious about you being
david choi being you know famous
musician does that get you a lot of
dates one would think that uh
you get a bunch of girls and stuff but
it's not the case it's not the case i
think it's it's tough it's tough for
everybody isn't it even for david choi
yeah i think so i mean at the same time
not like the type of guy who goes out
and i'm trying to get in the girl's
pants and stuff right you know i would
rather have a girl approach me i know it
sounds like a wussy thing to say but
i don't really like approaching that
much i just kind of like the more
natural like meet somebody they just say
hi and then we meet we talk and then we
get to know each other and then i'll be
like you know hey let's hang out but
for the most for the most part i don't
really go up to girls and i don't
usually initiate see that's interesting
to me because i mean you know you've
written your share of romantic songs and
girls they swoon over you so i mean
wouldn't that be really intimidating for
them to come up to you now if they did
come up to you if they did come up to
you and they're like oh my god you're
david choi
love you i love your songs can we go on
a date is that somebody that you would
go on a date with if they knew you like
that it'd be pretty ballsy of a girl to
do that to any guy i think yeah right
yeah so if they asked maybe maybe that's
a yes
yeah
so you heard it first on nmr with david
choi
if you see david choi and you love him
go ask him on a date immediately he will
say yes
that's a promise
oh here's your shout out
let's move into touring so you've done a
lot of touring a lot a lot of touring in
the last two years what are some of the
things that you've learned from
performing on stage so much i can hear
everything and i see everything too you
see all these faces
and uh something that's that's really
interesting is when people yawn and
things like that
i actually while i'm singing i'll be
looking in this direction i see like a
mouth open just like oh
and i look over here i'm like oh dang
he's yawning and then i just
focus my attention elsewhere while
trying to be in the moment
in the moment of the music but at the
same time i know that my music sometimes
people listen to when they go to sleep
so
um it makes sense so i'm not offended
well that's crazy so you actually do
notice individual reactions you can hear
everything when i hear like when i'm
singing a song and i hear like
i'm like immediately directed to that
that that noise and it's probably the
same with all the other you know
performers they notice that stuff so but
you don't let it get to you like
how i see people reacting it doesn't
change your set list or anything like
that right not really right um you just
kind of deal with it and you kind of
convince yourself that
it's natural and they're not bored
even if they are so i noticed that you
know before when you were booked for
concerts it was always it was mostly
acoustic they were all acoustic
performances but lately when you have
these concerts you've been you've toured
with a fuller band a full band yeah now
why is that change there when you have a
bunch of musicians on stage with you
you're allowed to screw up and nobody
can tell
good cobra
it's just more enjoyable to
perform your songs with with a full band
and uh i think it
gets across a different message as well
mm-hmm
ammonia
is a household cleaner
would you like to
try some of this poison
i'm thinking you like this cyanide
a big part of your audience is asian i
think undeniably big part of your
audience is asian why do you think that
is why do you think you appeal to an
asian audience i think i appeal to an
asian audience because i'm asian simply
but this whole youtube thing came about
and it revolutionized so many things in
this world asian kids
around the world or asian asian
americans in general would be able to
have entertainment i guess
of
people that look like themselves do you
ever think about that do you ever say oh
i need to reach beyond this main fan
base somehow
is that ever something that you think
about at the shows
i would say it's predominantly asian but
online it's it's not
well it's still predominantly asian but
there's a large percentage a very very
large percentage that are not asian that
are watching through youtube music has
no color or barrier um
it's just for everybody if it if the
song and the message
uh touches you in some way then you know
it's it's done its job do these things
ever feel restrictive to these labels
like being a youtube musician you know
or being an asian performer because
these are labels they are labels yeah
and i do come from youtube and i am
asian does it affect me personally not
really
everyone needs to put a label on
something when you think of someone's
music you describe it as like oh it's
kind of like justin timberlake meets you
know
french sinatra i don't know something
like that you know people put labels on
it so i guess it's a way for just humans
to define it so as an asian american is
there any specific element in your music
that you can say oh this affected that
this changed that i don't think being
asian has anything to do with you know i
i don't i don't really talk about asian
struggles or anything because i didn't
really have too many of those it's just
just human interactions i have a lot of
songs about death people don't know this
but um
it sounds
it sounds like it's not about death but
it actually is i think someday i'll
probably just
when i'm done i'm just like all right
this is what it really means i know it
made you happy but it's actually you
know
about killing yourself
when i wake up in the morning
you too
when you started off on youtube like a
lot of other uh artist musicians you
know you did covers do you think that
that's a good path to take do you think
that's the model path to take for
artists who are wanting to be discovered
on youtube or to grow it's a great way
to get a new fan base of people who are
looking for that song and they find your
rendition of it the goal is for me
personally at least is to direct them to
my original music and have them listen
to that it's a tough balancing act
because you don't want to be
known as like a cover artist i guess
that's one label that i wouldn't want to
be called this cover artist what can we
look forward to you from the near future
2013 i'm gonna focus back on my youtube
channel which i've neglected for the
past couple years no touring this year
but uh i will be doing some like
little shows here and there like i'm
going to hawaii next week
in february march i'm gonna go to
malaysia and singapore
um korea and japan in the summer time
and hit europe for the first time so you
will be i wouldn't you're not touring
yeah well yeah so i would a tour for me
is like
you know the grind just like city after
city after city for a long period of
time so now why have you decided to
start focusing back on your youtube
channel again whereas before it had been
neglected i'm inspired now the last six
months of 2012 was a time for me to
feel very confused about myself i think
what i was looking for was
a creative spark i never thought it i
didn't think it would come back but
luckily it did i kind of understand
myself a little better now it's just
about growth i think i think everyone
needs to be growing
in all parts of their lives to be able
to feel like you're in one piece
hey this is david choi uh thank you for
checking out my interview if you want to
see the full length you can check out
new
mediarockstars.com and uh you can check
out my youtube channel uh youtube.com
davidchonmusic i'm on twitter as well
davidjoymusic uh i hope you guys enjoyed
learning more about me and my life
and uh
make sure you subscribe follow me on
twitter catch you next time
hey this is david choi thank you guys so
much for watching my interview on
numeriarockstars.com
for the full length interview you can
check out uh
the link below and it'll direct you to
the the whole thing
check out my youtube channel it's dave
youtube.com davidjoymusic my twitter is
davidjoymusic as well facebook is david
choi um
to yeah
okay bye hey guys it's david choi thank
you so much for checking out the
interview go to new media rockstars
check out the full length interview with
awesome fire
burning pictures
um fire burning pictures um
awesome cool stuff
and
yeah
youtube.com slash david shaw music
la la la